salut et bienvenue dans il y fait tout
loi quand vous vous levez la nuit pour
aller aux toilettes
est-ce que vous allumer la lumière non
alors que vous seriez incapable de vous
déplacer chez un inconnu sans vous
prendre un meuble oui et oui monsieur
caca boudin et des enfants qui disent
monsieur caca boudin il parle d'âne ici
je pense c'est pas moi je reprend le fil
de ce qu'on disait chez soi on développe
un super pouvoir
on est capable de se faire un café les
yeux bandés je crois non ouais est ce
que tu penses que freddy gladieux
possède ce pouvoir
je sais pas eh ben c'est ce qu'on va
vérifier tout de suite ça est il un
super héros du quotidien
c'est parti on sonne le glas lieu il a
l'air bien réveillé il sait combien il
met un truc chez lui où il ne sait pas
quoi en fait c'est robben étage c'est
bien lui j'ai peur que ce soit la bonne
porte
ça va monsieur clavier vous savez là
aussi un moment j'ai une érection j'ai
froid c'est qu'on verra pas vos jolies
cuisses faire un insert dessus non c'est
vrai que c'est un peu gênant à m comme
jean menu que ça fait longtemps que vous
vivez ici je suis né quasiment cet
appart mais vous vivez salou ne vivait
plus avec vos parents depuis le temps il
ya mes parents chez moi d'accord vous
héberger vos parents du coup vous avez
dû reprendre des habitudes d'adolescents
genre cacher vos dvd porno alors
trouvèrent dvd c'est pas mieux ainsi que
si je suis de mes parents et du coup ça
va
quel est votre morning routine par
exemple être un peu trop
sur un stade je pense voir les stores et
vous réveiller et téléphone téléphone
pendant bon moment douchez jeu sort dans
la foulée je prends un petit déj d'orge
et donc la fin soit vous faites le matin
c'est les story après donc c'est le
petit le petit café la petit brossage de
dents j'imagine vous brosser les dents
jeanne est ce que tout ce que vous nous
avez dit est vrai mais monsieur gladieux
on est bien chez vous du coup oui t'as
pas vu mon bac +5 nom sur la boîte à
lettres
j'ai vu banderas et je me suis pas amusé
à antonio banderas qui habite alors quoi
eh bien écoutez si on est bien chez vous
vous allez pouvoir nous prouver alors je
vais vous demander de me suivre again et
vous allez ouvrir cette manette que tu
as ramené je peux toucher d'abord sans
voir vous avez bien toucher sans voir
les trucs tu auras l'occasion de le
faire c'est la sortie à votre tenue
sa sortie ok vous allez pouvoir nous
faire votre morning routine les yeux
fermés quand même équipe et au chaos
parce que ça serait quand même dommage
que tu te fasses bobos et en plus ça te
fait une belle gueule tu comprennes que
tout cas une seule manger ce truc là
mais en plus ça presse dessus monde là
pour le coup vraiment vraiment rien
quand il fait noir il fait noir et c'est
parti pour lui les deux noirs chiffre
est dit
il faut savoir que même si chez moi
comme tous les ans je me prends quand
même des fois les poignées quoi vous
êtes un super héros du kwassa saguenay
ravasi coucher ou qu'on va pouvoir
commencer votre petite journée
généralement je dors comme ça
naturellement d'accord énormément je
fais ça et je checke mais notifs
malaisie essayer d'aller sur un réseau
social et réseaux sociaux c'est à droite
un star après ses deux plus hauts ces
genres on stars presque un star c'est
marrant parce que vous n'avez pas une
fois lancé immeubles et vous avez des
doigts pas tactile enfin démenti sur la
1ère étape de votre morning
là je vais dans la cuisine des morgues
sont là j'ai deviné c'est qu'elle
quotidien golden moustache le tchèque à
gmail à partir du personnage inventé le
souffle ses proches louis café des cas
c'est le matin on parle également d'un
café classic
ça va je suis impressionné ok
dessous
là j'ai vraiment je garde des enfants je
sais c'est lui clamant d'ingouchie du
petit déj de chez vous mais bref vous
n'avez plus qu'à voir mon ego tine du
café j'ai envie de le boire tellement
elle est réussie votre café c'est
incroyable c'est le moment de faire un
puissance 4 avec anis mais les jaunes
c'est john sela 6 et 2 jaunes s'extraire
dijoux et choisir votre bandeau c'est
parti pour le puissance 4 les yeux
bandés prédit à vous l'honneur
[Musique]
c'est très bien parti pour vous deux si
tu te concentres sur le sont arrivés à
voir si on les met là ou là et là il met
tous à droite est foutue l'aimé tout
cela joue à gauche un peu en déficit il
n'ya pas puissance 4 bah si mais
pourquoi dit il a même pas fait exprès
je n'en ai pas fait comment ça je pense
que ça va chaque matin je me dira que le
puissance 4
alors une petite récompense vous avez
droit à une petite collation surtout qui
m'a puissance cas c'est sympa c'est que
j'ai demandé ce matin quand vous veniez
est ce que vous vous trouviez m'apporter
un petit belge de rester on va de
morning routing avait pas de petit déj
un p'tit déj dehors oui bah c'est pour
ça que je vous montre un petit déj
vous allez avoir trois gobelets avec des
trucs dedans vous allez devoir mélanger
deux de ces gobelets il ya des chances
pour que ce soit bon si vous mourrez pas
dans un des gobelets vous aurait de
l'eau dans un dico plaît vous aurez de
la grenadine et un gobelet avec de
l'huile d'olive parce qu'il ya aussi des
gens qui prennent de l'huile d'olive le
matin tu exactement à cuba je crois
qu'il faut alors vous savez pas ce que
vous faites mais c'est ma [ __ ] avant
tout à fait désolé parce que c'est ici
généralement que j'ouvre mon tiroir pour
prendre une cuillère celui qui est le
plus rempli j'imagine que c'est flou il
ya un truc de ça c'est frais c'est de
nous là bas je suis navré les gars je
dois savoir ce qui est de l'huile ou de
la grenadine
alice est d'origine algérienne ici que
ça ne gâche pas de l'huile d'olive je
pense que le ver le moins remplie c'est
l'huile de livres ça c'est l'huile
d'olive parce qu'il y en a moins et ça
c'est là que vous allez changer d'avis
au dernier moment
[Musique]
moralement cela bouge comme tout le
monde c'est à dire comme ça a pu aller
voilà c'est officiel je suis humide mais
vous l'avez fait non oui non [ __ ] n'en
moyenne ce qu'est la nuit ont fait là
moi ça c'est mouillé la wii vous avez
jeté de l'eau partout le défi tennis
monsieur gladieux c'est un défi que
chaque participant à ce programme sont
donc là vous avez de la chance vous
allez rentrer dans un classement
j'ai le premier mondial dans la même
minute
vous allez faire rebondir cette balle et
l'a rattrapé le plus de fois possible
oui vous attendez monde est content
donc on a une minute c'est parti 1 0
oui pas mal
il vous reste 18 secondes ils vont être
six secondes vous féliciter vous avez
droit à une collation d'huile d'olive
est-ce que freddy est un super héros du
quotidien
franchement way et prédit que tu as donc
droit de signer le livre d'or de
l'émission les yeux les yeux bandés
oui les yeux bandés
depuis le temps il ya les parents celle
du coup c'est de cacher vos dvd pornos
je suis de mes parents c'est vous qui si
vous voulez vous voulez c'est vous qui
c'est vous qui décidez où vous écrivez
dans ce livre d'or inscrite autres
droits écrit bien tu peux le lire voir
si c'est bien écrit un vrai batteur n'en
bonheur de batteries à nice à l'us open
sans suite
c'est une vise à ce que j'ai très bien
l'église ça et vous avez signé arturo
brachetti buzz est trop peu de gars vous
avez le droit d'enlever votre masque
avec le plus dur c'est à nice a pas
voulu le faire
freddy alice m'emmener chez toi pour
tester superpouvoirs sais qui tu as
envie de l'emmener toi jean dujardin
un autre beau tatouage gilles lellouche
un gars que tu connais albert dupontel
c'est pas un bateau toi tu vas là j'ai
pas là wayne swan a beaucoup j'espère
qu'ils voudraient bien c'était sympa en
tout cas et ça fait plaisir de voir que
freddy aussi est un super héros du
quotidien km répond bien sûr sur 10
hockey a noté fred et dans les
commentaires sur dix et abonnez vous à
toutes les chaînes respectives de tous
ces gens ont tué en mai date future
tâche n est pas si vous
abonnez vous abonnez-vous à la mienne à
celle de freddy a pas de piège dans le
pied ces combats si l'on croisé quelques
sites éducatifs
[Musique]